Going back to the wireframes.
In the phone layout,
we wanted the Today item
to be a little bit bigger,
but on the tablet's, we just want it
to look like all the other items,
because we have an
expanded detail pane here.
To do this in the forecast adapter
newView method,
we should return the layout
for a list item forecast
not for the today layout.
Then in the bindView method,
for the today item,
we should use the gray icon
instead of the colored icon.
These decisions get controlled
by the return value
of the getItemViewType method.
Therefore we modify
the getItemViewType method
so that at the zero position,
if we have to use
the special today layout,
then we return View type today.
Otherwise, if we shouldn't use
the special today layout,
then we should just return
the View type for all future days.
This Boolean is controlled
by the setter method.
To access this Boolean,
we created a public setter method
on the forecast adapter.
But who knows how
to set this value properly?
Well the main activity knows
whether it's one-pane or two-pane UI.
So, it can decide whether we should use
the special today layout or not.
We don't have access
to the forecast adapter here,
but we can plumb the values
through the ForecastFragment.
To get access to the ForecastFragment,
we can ask the fragment manager
and pass it the fragment ID.
Finish changing the code
so the app looks like this.